so I guess the easiest way to put it is
manufacturing using 3d printers will it
create a net positive of jobs and will
it be moved back to the US great
question it will in the US I think it is
it's a net positive for places that have
seen manufacturing jobs leave their
country right I would say China is
probably gonna be in trouble I read a
blog post recently about how Foxconn is
looking to automate 30 percent of their
workforce in the next three years I
think they have a million employees
right so that's 300,000 people that
might lose their jobs due to automation
the hope obviously is that things are
growing right it's not a zero-sum game
and so why are they losing jobs they're
gonna be replaced by robotics they send
a low-cost option essentially and now
robots are the low-cost option you can
deploy them anywhere so they're they're
getting beaten at their own game
essentially and help us understand why
in particular this is happening today
how are the robots of today any better
in terms of their technology or
capabilities than the robots we've seen
for a long time yeah I think there's a
few trends that are converging robots
are becoming a lot cheaper is so just
focusing on the hardware side first we
actually use a collaborative robot you
are 10 it's called and this is a $35,000
robot so depending on your perspective
that's either really expensive or really
cheap it's cheap if you're used to
spending money on hundred and fifty
thousand dollar robots the other
advantage of the collaborative bots is
that you can just plop them into a work
environment and you don't have to spend
a ton of money on safety equipment
robots are really dangerous because if
you're like working around them it will
able to just kill you honestly if you're
in the wrong place at the wrong time so
these are designed to accommodate that
by you know they have force sensing and
stuff like that so they don't hurt
people
this started as a research trend in
Boston with this company called rethink
robotics and they released their first
arm in like 2011 so not only did the
price come too
but they also kind of got easier to
integrate into the workplace you can
actually train them now just by like
taking an arm and dragging it to a place
and saying like move here and like move
here well go into that a little bit
deeper because we talked about it when
you were giving me the tour like I'm
very curious about how you actually
program an arm there are so many
different ways the software side of it I
think is the other interesting part of
the industry which is pretty pretty
young there's at all you can probably
talk to this even more but there's kind
of like software of old with robotics
which is very rigid and structured and
focused around safety and then there's
like software of new which is all five
years old or less and most of that has
been developed around this one system
called Ross robot operating system and
Ross is really exciting for the industry
because it's very accessible you can
program it it's open-source but it
obviously has a lot of a lot of things
to be improved before it's like quite
ready for highly structured environments
where reliability is key I don't know
you could probably talk a little bit
more about what we've been planning on
doing here yeah I mean the the
cooperative arms are really nice because
even before you get to the level of we
need to integrate Ross to add vision or
something else like that the you are 10
is actually at the point where you just
pop open a socket and send it some ascii
commands and you have it moving around
immediately so the interface there is
really easy and actually we've been able
to treat most of our robotics projects
to this point just as software projects
we're definitely interested in bringing
people in with robotics automation
experience who can sort of handle or
think about the corner cases more and
things like recovering from failure but
as far as getting a prototype together
it's basically just a software project
okay and so to make this more clear like
how are you guys actually integrating
robots because you know on the surface
you're doing 3d printing and those are
confined boxes so why do you need arms
3d printers are robots I'm just gonna
say definition ok
we're definitely adding adding more to
the mix so I think the cool thing
it's it's actually a pretty
straightforward application of the arm
and it's something that people have been
using robotics for for awhile which is
just your classic machine tending so
basically you know you have some high
value piece of equipment that's churning
out these jobs for you you want to be
able to run it 24/7 so you just have an
arm sit there and your machine is so
high value that every second you can
keep it producing is worth money to your
company we actually have a slightly more
exaggerated case of that where we have
you know 160 3d printers so it's not
one-armed tending one machine like I
think you tend to see in the traditional
deployment of this technology we have
one arm tending fifty or a hundred
machines so it's very valuable to us
essentially to be able to to do
something like this with the arm okay
and so why have you guys opted for the
machines the 3d printers that you've
gone with we we use big about replicator
twos we use them because we know they
work and we we actually used to work at
MakerBot the manufacturer of the printer
and so when we were there we obviously
got a lot of experience with these
they're kind of older technology at this
point so we're definitely looking to
integrate the next thing pretty soon
mm-hmm and because they're like so
people understand the landscape there's
a whole range or 3d printers right like
in the past I mean when did it start
like 20 years ago people started doing
3d printing 83 I think was like the
first like patent around 3d printing so
in the past 30 years
expensive printers like $100,000
printers the cheapest printer was maybe
like $20,000 printers have been the name
of the game and these are all used for
prototypes starting in around 2007 those
original patents expired and people
started developing desktop printers
which is what really spurred the 3d
printing explosion of like 2012 and fall
from maybe you know there was kind of
this curve of like oh my god we're
really excited about 3d printing
everything is going to be 3d printed
then the reality set in there's a lot of
work that needs to be done before we're
there so cheap printers which is the
desktop printers that we use are just
low-end commoditize hardware the
technology was invented you know a few
decades ago and people just figure out
how to make them really cheaply in scale
and that's what we're built on and you
guys have opted into those cheaper
printers just so you can have more jobs
running simultaneously it's it's the
Google Amazon method to reliability
essentially and it sort of flips the
current or old style 3d Service Bureau
on its head very valuable machines
creating very valuable parts in small
quantities for us it's all about scale
and and cheap parts so going back to
robotics for a second if I'm listening
to this podcast today and I'm kind of
interested in getting into robotics but
I don't really know where to start what
should I do
that's a great question there are really
cheap robotic arms out there that you
would start with so like craig and i
were actually talk about this earlier
you can buy like a five axis arm which
is you know servos yeah there's a few
different ones I actually haven't heard
of that one they use servos they can
lift a few hundred grams and you can
just like put on your desk and have it
like you know move your pen from one
point to the other you know and you can
actually obviously add more complex
tasks on top of that so pick up one of
those and then start using one of the
open-source libraries out there
programming a robotic arm is a lot
easier than maybe it was a long time ago
because they handle all the complicated
stuff like how do you get from point A
to point B you can kind of just tell it
move to these coordinates and XYZ and
then sometimes you tweak it a little bit
for like how it moves there but the
details are handled right now by
software that's been developed over the
last 10 20 years and when you guys are
programming your larger cool or arm are
you doing any of it in simulation are
there any good software packages to be
to be had there
I think we we had an intern working on
on that project over the summer and I
think just at the end he discovered some
simulation tools and yes basically you
can you can get a simulation that shows
your environment shows actually this is
one of the built-in features to Ross
it's just a module that you can include
and it'll let you simulate and just sort
of show you exactly where the bot is or
if you're running simulations where you
think it is
so the tooling around this I think has
been improving and actually today is in
a you know it has a lot of things that
we could use but it's it's in a pretty
good spot today I think that's also an
excellent point to bring up because that
is going to be the future of Robotics
simulating so that the robot can teach
itself how to do things and basically
humans can train robots to do more kind
of like objective oriented tasks and
then it can figure out the details for
you our goal is to eventually build a
system for let's say assembling a
product that we're making on an assembly
line we would love an arm that is
dexterous enough to replicate actions
that human hands can do and maybe just
have like a video camera and have a
human assemble one and then the arm will
teach itself how to do that from a video
that would be amazing
that is what we want to build I think
that requires simulation is what we're
working towards interesting and does
anyone manufacture today anything that
resembles human dexterity in terms of
you know fingers so there's there's
definitely some robot arms that are
meant to like grab objects and they have
fingers and they're slow they're not the
best there's probably two two movements
when it comes to like grippers in the
robotics world there's the hard you know
rigid like one or two AXI actuators and
then there's the soft grippers so the
hard actuators you designed to do one
task and like you optimize it for that
and it can do that over and over again
and it's cheap and simple this
soft actuators which are not as mature
are kind of designed to like pick up
objects that are weird like this without
breaking it a lot of them even work with
like air sacks that just kind of like
closed around things and those really
aren't dexterous enough for precise
enough I haven't seen anything yet
that is like as good as a human hand
just kind of weird following the line of
training yourself to learn robotics
where are the areas that you see
developing right now that are super
interesting in high value to companies
where people can start contributing to
to open-source projects so if I were in
undergrad or getting my Master's right
now I would be learning Ross and I would
be focusing on research that was towards
that training problem this is also
problem that opening eye is working on
and has published some cool videos and
papers about if you're really just
looking to get a job there's kind of two
flavors of Robotics right now there's
like the research side which is what
we're talking about and then there's the
industrial automation side industrial
automation is very different industrial
automation is about performing one task
over and over again really efficiently
and cost-effectively companies most
manufacturing companies will invest
hundreds of thousands of dollars
building a machine that just does one
thing really efficiently so it's not
flexible is the main difference to do
that you need to be a mechanical
engineer an electrical engineer and have
a little bit of software knowledge and
then you can become an industrial
automation expert and go work you know
for Toyota automating their next
assembly line or Tesla may be a little
bit cooler so there there are two paths
there's the research path which is
probably more interesting for the
intellectual folks who like to think
about problems that have been solved yet
and then there's the industrial
automation path which is a little bit
more practical a little bit more like
classical engineer I'm just gonna like
build stuff in so Daniel what's come
across your desk with the AI grants
related to robotics yes so Justin back
color AI grant is
a kind of decentralized research lab
where people can fill out an application
in about five minutes and within a
couple of weeks we let them know for
giving them a grant for what that has
both cash and twenty thousand dollars in
GPU training credits and we've gotten
almost a thousand applications for the
second round of AI grant
many of them focus on of the ones
involved in robotics they're almost all
entirely in simulation
the advantage to simulation is you could
do this from you know your pajamas at
home you don't have to buy anything and
they all they're all kind of very
similar to the work opening eyes trying
to do where you want to give an agent a
video feed like a human would get and
try to get it to learn to do something I
you know all of the approaches are kind
of as far as I could tell somewhat
similar to what general research is
doing so if you have to come across
something incredibly different and weird
but I'm eager to find it and help that
person get their paper published if they
have if they're listening to this
podcast now yeah well what are the
approaches people are using because I
don't think it's I mean AI is obviously
of interest to many people but robotics
specifically within a I like how
training in a simulation even works
could you just walk through that for
people who want to understand yeah
and and I'm sure they're there folks
that are significantly more expert in
this than me but the rough idea is even
beyond a simulation in reality which
what you're doing is you set up a camera
and you use you know about the 2014-15
technology that we we've uncovered as a
species which is we've managed to teach
computers how to look inside images to
get a general understanding of what the
agent is looking at and then you'll
traditionally you'll have you know
ideally a human performance ask so you
know you're moving a ball from one hand
to another or you moving a ball from one
point to another and then there's kind
of two sinner
here there's one we're totally on a
free-form basis the robot arm will try
to do the same exact thing and it's just
trying to emulate what the human hand
saw there's another approach which is
that the robot arm has some type of goal
function that it is looking to maximize
and so it kind of flails around and
realizes okay like randomly moving
around in space bad idea because that's
not increasing my goal function
you know touching this ball seemingly
slightly better you know moving this
ball across the coordinates of the right
place even better and so in particular
this is done with things that where you
could measure very clearly the objective
function like unscrewing a cap from a
bottle and then you basically try to
match those two things together into an
end-to-end system as far as I can tell
this at a truly end-to-end system you
know that the works in the physical
world I don't think has been
demonstrated by anyone yet but but I may
be wrong
there was one gnarly unnamed research
lab that had a just a goal Maximizer
robot arm I think with a bottle cap and
this thing was it wasn't even given any
image priors it was just he'll try to
unscrew the cap and so the arm which is
quite strong is flailing around trying
to unscrew the cap and it's it's not
smart it's just trying to unscrew the
cap you know don't don't blame it and
then apparently the store so the server
is told it grabs onto a researchers arm
and it's like oh let me try to squeeze
in screws okay that's not working
I said no harm was done but I think it's
an interesting example to how a I true
AI could be actually like not evil
pretty harmless it's just doing this
other thing where it just wants to get
more paperclips and then by accident
destroys this all yeah hopefully the
goal function isn't like take over the
world launch nuclear missiles I guess my
point is even with a simple goal
function like get more energy to run
faster you could accidentally kind of
cause a lot of damage protect humans
from themselves kill them all I mean
who's putting in the bounds right now
obviously open AI is doing ton of
research around this but yeah I mean
when you hit a level of intelligence
maybe slightly passed unscrewing
someone's arm word of Constraints people
are trying to create an AI right now boy
it's an active area of research and
tweeting of Elon Musk so I mean I think
there's a lot of people working on safe
AI I'm personally pretty skeptical on
the regulation approach that people keep
on proposing because it's not clear to
me how you could make it global and and
I don't think that you know all the
smart people are in America I think
they're spread across the world so I
think regulation would just mean that
America's lost to the game I think
there's folks working on you know kind
of failsafe
or Deadman switch is something that
would stop an algorithm before it starts
hitting folk hurting other humans
there's people working on algorithms
that are cooperative in their style so
open and deep mind actually published a
paper on this where that the training is
done with a human in the loop who's
actively making suggestions and the
hypothesis I believe is that well if
that would always happen at least the
human could direct the AI to be like Oz
bad
let's stop hurting my arm type of thing
and I'm sure there's plenty other
approaches that I'm not not even aware
of
I am personally I haven't heard it's
it's quite fascinating when there's a
area like this there's an open problem
which is the AGI problem which we're all
aware of we're all talking about you
know over dinner oh my gosh what's gonna
happen and no one's really thought of a
clean answer and it's kind of made me
wonder if there is one at all because
it's one of those things where I feel
like who's an obvious one it would have
it would have come up by now there's a
lot of smart people thinking about it
and so I've kind of resigned myself to
believe that from AGI you know killing
us it's not clear to me that there is a
smart answer
I mean depressingly if you go online you
read stories about what we do to other
species we consider less intelligent
right we're not that moral like there's
a great slash very sad reddit thread
about how people abuse characters from
The Sims oh no and you know we all did
this you know you like build a house
put him in the pool and then you take
out the yeah the ladder and we all
thought it was hilarious but you think
about it and you're like well that's
kind of the same thing if you
superimpose it onto a super smart AI to
us obviously we crush ants without
giving it another thought I am skeptical
that we will find a way to fix that I am
optimistic that that that's not gonna be
what kills us as a species though okay I
because I think there are far more
threatening things that are closer for
example the use of AI by a human to
create some you know some type of
nefarious damage so what's what's
happening is there's this AI hype right
now and so more and more industries are
moving their infrastructure to kind of
non-deterministic machine learning based
stuff cars are going to be using machine
learning to drive the electricity grid
will manage itself using machine
learning and so as a result it will be
more susceptible to attacks from that
same thing as opposed to being manned by
a human and so the power grid is now
constantly being regulated by an
algorithm instead of a human could that
algorithm be interrupted by another
smarter algorithm in a way that would
been easier than to interrupt the human
eye I think so
so I suspect war will actually not be
from a GI war and damage and carnage
will be from weaponized dumb AI yeah
well to kind of like concretely connect
the dots
your robots currently right now are
fixed to the ground but they're going to
start moving at some point right yeah
they're gonna be put on mobile bases not
dissimilar from like a table azad
warehouse right and so have you begun
that training process
no we've gotten a few demos but the
hardware is actually really early when
Amazon acquired Kiva they just took that
out of the market and so right around
now is when people are starting to
release mobile bases again but they're
all in beta I think there are a few that
you can actually buy so no we haven't
gotten started on the moving problem wow
so amazon's acquisition of Kiva you
think this kind of slowdown innovation
like five years Wow something like that
it took a long time for everyone else to
catch up yeah what about the the
automated can I mean have you been to a
shipping container port ever I grew up
in Long Beach California there's a
massive
yeah but I haven't like got the tour
there are basically trailers that are
autonomous I wonder I don't know who is
producing those but I don't think it was
Cuban no keep it just does warehouse
robot yeah that's what I thought which
is all like they can play picking pack
and stuff like that okay I think that's
also the the shipyard example is an
interesting it's an interesting example
that shows how robotics scale in a way
that humans don't you could build a
little mini shipping yard and train it
on that or do it digitally right - it
totally is a simulation and then roll it
out and start moving around like
multi-ton objects very quickly yeah
that's just a process that doesn't scale
like it scales weight more efficiently
than a human process does which is a
little bit scary what challenges do you
guys see if you wanted to scale to like
a hundred thousand square-foot warehouse
you know for us it's actually so right
now what we're building is kind of like
this footprint unit Factory which has
160 printers and we'll have like two
arms moving around doing machine tending
and then as parts come off of the
printers they have to be post-process QC
packed and shipped out I think when we
automate each of those steps they each
scale very easily most of the challenges
getting the first part of it automated
everything beyond that is kind of like
can you buy the hardware quickly enough
and traditional software scaling issues
many of which are solved so going from a
1,800 square foot factory to a hundred
thousand square foot Factory is kind of
like how many more arms do we need and
like how many AWS servers do we need to
send up it's an engineering problem it
actually doesn't seem that hard dude as
CTO
I mean so yeah I think there are
probably economies of scale that we
could realize in a hundred thousand
square foot space that we obviously
can't get here but yeah I mean the easy
answer to scaling would just be pound
this footprint out as many times as we
can into that hundred thousand square
foot space and we know basically like we
will keep costs basically where they are
to
but you know then we can slowly merge
cells reorganize as we need to so this
is sort of our worst case scenario right
now but we could in theory pop these
open across the country if we needed to
hmm
it's very different from scaling a
factory traditionally and this is a
contentious top topic but scaling a
factory of robots is so much easier than
scaling factory of people hiring people
is difficult as everyone knows hiring
people who are good hiring people who
you know show up to work on time etc
hiring people in a different country if
your company doesn't speak that language
it's difficult you know requires an
on-the-ground expert in the theoretical
fully automated Factory case none of
those problems are real hmm if you can
run a hundred thousand square foot
factory or a hundred thousand machine
factory with 200 people it's a lot
easier than like a thousand people
running a factory so that's I mean kind
of the idea that Voodoo's built on is
it'll be a lot easier to scale as we
build out this footprint right but
you're also factoring in being really
close to many people who are interested
in manufacturing right I heard on one
podcast that you offer like pickup for
certain folks yeah is it still the case
yeah
I'll be worried Brooklyn we're right
outside up ahead okay so do you have a
vision of just you know many factories
or would you rather one giant one we
think of it kind of like server farms
it's semi local so maybe there's not a
server from right down the street from
everyone in the world but there might be
one within one day delivery distance
yeah or potentially in pickup distance
for for larger customers it's actually
really common in manufacturing for a
company like Toyota to contract with
somebody who's gonna make you know a sub
component of one of their cars and then
require them to set up a factory right
next to the Toyota factory with like a
conveyor belt literally moving the parts
from one to the other it's kind of a
crazy thing that they can just say we're
gonna work together but you're gonna
build this factory right next to us
we're not going to build it you are
that's also a lot easier with a robotic
Factory you know and you can you can
customize it so it's just the right size
on the topic of Toyota how do you kind
of see the future of the materials that
you can use in 3d printing evolving so
today I think when people think of 3d
printing they think of the like
basically little plastic parts are you
always going to be stuck with that or is
there a strategy where that kind of
changes in expands so our vision for
Vudu is definitely to move past just 3d
printing but even within 3d printing you
know it's been around since the 80s I
think Boeing is 3d printing titanium
parts for all of their planes now so 3d
printing as a technology if you consider
the entire range is a very capable
technology and you know generally
technology trickles down to the low end
that's what we'll see here so Vudu is
building an infrastructure for
onboarding digital manufacturing
technologies so it doesn't matter if
it's 3d printing if it's capable of
doing plastic metal whatever you know
we're interested in anything that takes
a digital file as input and outputs a
physical object at the end so that's how
we're going to handle the quality and
material questions that come up we got a
question from from Twitter about the
future of 3d printing
and this point is probably the biggest
barrier to like a 3d printer being in
everyone's home 3d printers just right
now don't have the material capabilities
or the multi-material capabilities to
produce most of the objects in your
house right most things are a
combination of plastic components
multi-step plastic components electrical
you know PCBs wiring soldering batteries
like all of this stuff which is
currently assembled it seems like people
don't think about when they say the
future is gonna be a 3d printer in my
house making my stuff maybe like 1% of
the objects you own could be made by a
3d printer right now because they're
just a single material so
I think eventually we're gonna hit that
future where it's like the Star Trek
replicator mm-hmm
it's not gonna happen with any of the
current technologies out there until
then digital manufacturing is still a
thing
digital file the physical product but
it's gonna be a multi-step process which
I think benefits from economies of scale
from a centralized facility what verse
yeah what about even just literal
objects kill just a plastic on this
chair yeah what is the time frame look
like to where we could just have 3d
printers making at least this part for
us yeah
3d printing right now is not super
cost-effective for big stuff meaning big
meeting anything larger than like a loaf
of bread okay when you get bigger than
that
it just gets prohibitively expensive and
so printing that chair might cost a few
hundred dollars there are big printers
out there so people are definitely
working on that problem but you kinda
have to balance quality with speed and
so I think the next wave of 3d printed
parts in the world and digital
manufactured parts are all gonna be like
consumer packaged goods like smaller
things that fit kind of again and just
like loaf of bread size shape yeah
you're not gonna start printing tables
and houses and stuff without significant
improvements of the technology okay and
it's just expensive because it's a large
amount of plastic it really comes down
to the extrusion rate of the Machine so
let's say that that share is either
injection molded or roto molded
different moulding technologies you have
like a physical mold which costs
probably tens of thousands of dollars to
make and you have a machine that very
rapidly injects hot plastic into it and
so the the rate of injection of those
machines is probably like a thousand
times faster than your average 3d
printer so based on that fact alone you
know you can just take the cost of the
Machine time and the injection rate and
approximate how much it costs to build
something and large objects just are too
expensive the ratios don't work
yet so there's one handful of questions
from Twitter one is about IP in China
you remember this one yeah so Wyatt
Sanders asked how do you deal with
intellectual property in China how hard
is it finding support for new hardware
as opposed to software I'm trying to
understand the question exactly I read
it and I have a few questions about the
question but I'll do my best since this
is a in person question so honestly I
you know I think with IP unless you're
incredibly restrictive about like what
gets out basically anything that isn't a
well guarded trade secret somebody else
will have the most interesting I guess
story I heard is when you're
manufacturing in China IP is thought
about very differently than it is here I
think there's kind of this belief that
like things are just shared and so
that's why you like everybody gets the
sneak peek of an iPhone because in
reality culturally let that culturally
it's not a big as big of a deal to just
kind of like share stuff I feel like so
it's very different in China than it is
in the u.s. so if you're getting
something made in China I wouldn't
really count on IP being a big factor
and even if you can keep something
totally under wraps like let's say
you're building a top-of-the-line drone
or something
once this out of the market somebody in
China will buy one and then in like two
or three months just replicate it mm-hmm
it's not very difficult for them to do
that with hardware hardware is becoming
easier and easier to replicate over time
and so it's getting closer to software
so I think hardware IP will actually
work a little bit more like software IP
which is difficult to protect so
actually an interesting to talk about
voodoo again a little bit and where we
fit into this one of the benefits of
digital manufacturing is that you're not
rebuilding your molds all the time when
your
iterating on your product so actually
the avenue for manufacturing companies
protect protecting their products could
be just iterating more rapidly and using
companies like us to really stay ahead
of the market
mm-hmm how did Apple think about it
you'd have to ask them no comment all
right next question
Enrique asks I don't know if you would
even have an answer to this but um 3d
printed solar panels have you heard of
this no I didn't even see that question
came in on Facebook man I don't know
anything about to do that yes yeah what
do we have any context for this question
the context is and I'm adding a word
here what has been the progress
regarding 3d solar panels which I assume
means 3d printed solar panels got it
my guess is middle a lot of like
processes that you use in making chips
or dealing with silicon wafers have the
same names as 3d printing processes so
there's like stereo lithography is a
common way of getting parts 3d printed
basically that just means you have like
a laser that's itching some pattern into
something so I can imagine a world where
you can make solar panels with three
versions but I actually don't know
anything about it all right next
question then bit-bit asks what will 3d
printing will it ever be incorporated
into our educational system the other
way the way other technologies have
definitely that's a pretty simple answer
yeah I mean I actually the first time I
used a 3d printer was in high school oh
really
yeah to go to high school I went to this
really nerdy school in California called
the California Academy of math and
science it was a public school but they
got sponsorships from like engineering
companies to help us get things like 3d
printers so yeah I think it's definitely
moving in that direction and that when I
was in high school that the $2,000
printer didn't exist so it was a big
deal to have this like $30,000 machine
in the
you know that we could use hmm so
machines are cheap enough there they
cost the same amount as a computer it'll
just follow the same trend like
computers started ending up in
classrooms in the 90s right yeah so if
today is the 90s of computers in 20
years right I think kids will probably
using them to make all sorts of things
okay I did have a couple questions about
just your experience in YC were you guys
in this group reading Daniels group yes
yeah yes we were now I can connect the
dots we can talk about Daniel off the
record but what was your uh what was
your experience like it well I see being
a hardware company do you find it was
any different ah yes I mean we're we're
not quite a hardware company is the
other side of it so we I think before we
went to IC we didn't quite know how to
position ourselves with investors or
other people because we're not a
hardware company we're not a software
company exclusively so I think being in
YC and talking to Daniel and talking to
Sam basically helped us find ourselves
as a robotics company that's that's
really what it comes down to which is
the intersection of hardware and
software and if we succeed in the future
we will have contributed significant
gains to the world of robotics and
automation in manufacturing hmm do you
remember what they were like in the
beginning yeah grabbing pretty pretty
formidable I think they were more
formidable by the end though and I think
why see the hope is that Y C gives
founders a lot of things but one that
often people discount because it's I
think a little bit hard to capture in a
couple of bullet points you can read on
the Internet is it really changes
founders mentality and the way they
think of just how big their company
could be and I'm not saying that you
guys were Myka when you came in you were
already great you had already had a
great business but I have found that
with the the Voodoo founders and and a
lot of other folks it it hopefully takes
it to the next
in terms of figuring out how to position
their company when talking to investors
internally and frankly to themselves
hmm um a question we get often times is
uh what is it like being a solo founder
and why I see you guys are kind of on
the opposite end of the spectrum with
four correct correct what's that
experience been like uh we had a it was
actually really helpful for us because
we're based in New York and ycs
obviously in California we kind of had
this dilemma because we can't just move
the whole company there when we get into
IC we have a factory we've got people so
it was really helpful to kind of break
up going to YC on different weeks so
that we could focus on like building
things here but also make sure that
somebody was there like talking to
partners getting advice building the
company otherwise you know I think our
founding story kind of goes back to the
fact that we've known each other for a
long time we founded a previous company
together
sold that company and the typical
pitfalls that you would find with a
four-person team we've been lucky to
avoid usually with four people I'd
imagine you run into like serious issues
of like who owns what or you know two
people might not get a longer that there
could be so many different problems
because your your graph gets bigger we
are used to working together so luckily
we haven't had any any issues then
Oliver maybe you can confer no i would
just agree with what max is saying i
think it's important to sort of carve
out roles for everybody and making sure
that people are getting input to the
things that they're really bringing
value to but at a certain point you know
not everybody is involved with every
decision day to day right on a large
founding team I think that sometimes
hurts feelings or rubs people the wrong
way but for us I think we've done a
pretty good job of defining what
everyone's role is on the team and
making the hard decisions together but
also making sure that you know we're not
taking things personally when hey
somebody had a meeting and a decision
was made
it's it's I think everybody buys into
the idea that we're a team and we're
doing this together and everybody's got
a part to play there even if it's not
always exactly in the direction they
want to go mm-hmm
just for folks that are listening to
this inner maybe single founder is
wondering how to meet co-founders how
how did you guys originally all meet we
have a very funny story I would say no
sorry go on
so voodoo has four founders three of us
went to college together
Oliver was actually that great above me
and John who's one of our founders John
and I actually kind of decided we wanted
to start a company while we were juniors
we had internships that summer that we
like didn't like so we dropped them
starting a company Oliver had graduated
already and had a job at teradata
and we convinced him to quit his job and
move back to Claremont which is where we
went to school and live in a house with
two people who were still in school so I
I was doing training with teradata I'd
been there I think for six weeks or
something like that and I had to go quit
basically during a training program and
so that was difficult and then and then
had to move basically across the street
from the college I had just graduated is
a bit humbling at the time but clearly
sitting here I think the right decision
well what was that pitch like because
that that's another very common question
like how do I convince someone to join
my team that's that's a really good
question I'm interested in hearing
Oliver's perspective because the other
weird thing about our our histories we
weren't like best friends before we
started our first company I kind of knew
John and John kind of knew Oliver
because we went to a small school and I
was in a class with John did you know
Oliver at all I don't think we'd met
until you guys were pitching me on
joining so there was a little bit of
risk right which is why I think we got
really lucky yeah
that our personalities were compatible
we went to a really like tech focus
school so I think just coming from the
same environment was a good starting
point but to get back to your question
the pitch was do you want to start a
company and you know selling him on the
future of 3d printing which at the time
was really easy because it was
everywhere I remember one night we had
to drive down to San Diego and get
dinner with all of his parents and
convinced them that it was also very
old-fashioned yeah yeah almost like we
were dating right I don't know what
happened from from your self yeah I mean
the pitch was basically do you want to
do fun stuff or not and I wasn't feeling
super fulfilled in the position I was at
so I tend to be a very cautious and a
cautious person I like to think of like
you know worst-case scenarios and stuff
like that this was a very out of
character decision for me I think to
just sort of bail on a job and jump in
but it worked out I think a lot of it
comes down to timing right it's they
just they got me at the right time
I was not their first choice actually
which i think is an important thing to
bring up just because for a solo founder
out there who's trying to find somebody
to make it work doesn't have to be your
first choice doesn't have to be your
second choice there's somebody out there
that you can probably build this company
with mm what were the technical
capabilities of the other people on the
team when they were trying to bring you
on so it was just the two of them
they're both engineering or they had
their engineering degrees or we're
getting them at the time so really they
were looking for a someone with a
software background to you know join the
team and sort of take on that that part
of the company so that's the role I came
on for that's the role I filled
basically ever since is sort of owning
the software side of the product mm-hmm
do you have any pro tips Daniel on what
about finding finding and then
convincing
a co-founder um I was a single founder
at some point during YC and then I found
someone who became a very good friend of
mine to be my co-founder but we've it
was a risky decision because I met him
after YC his name is Robby and we spent
maybe maybe a total of 48 72 hours
together coding together talking before
we made the jump and so we kind of
really lucked out in that way it's not
like a theme yeah the one non-intuitive
thing or semi non-intuitive thing that I
would encourage I always encourage
people to think about is as it turned
out for my interaction with Robby the
fact that we were destined to be really
good friends mattered more than the fact
that we both worked well together and so
what I mean in particular is as it turns
out we had the same shared taste in
music
we'd fairly similar political beliefs we
had fairly similar hobbies we liked the
same video games and that context I
found matters quite a bit because you
end up spending a lot of your waking
hours with this person and in some of
those hours are quite stressful so it's
useful to have this shared substrate of
you know oh we both you know like
deadmau5 or something to fall back on
versus find just shooting for someone
who is you know technically competent
mm-hmm I would agree with that point
wholeheartedly yeah Oliver and John are
two of my best friends and they weren't
before we started our first company five
or six years ago yeah and a lot of that
is we go to concerts together like we go
to sports games we were roommates for
four or five years yeah I still live
with John yeah all ended up cause he's a
girlfriend so good for him but that I
think that was key to us cuz we actually
just enjoyed spending all that time
together yep so I mean I think one way
to encapsulate this is if you're looking
for a co-founder maybe more better to
start looking I know this sounds kind of
lonely but start looking for someone who
could be a really good friend and then
and then and then your second filter is
if they're technical or not mmm as
opposed to the opposite yeah that's a
great point
so maybe kind of enclosing you guys have
been out of YC for a while now six
months yeah what's your advice for other
YC companies
that like I know the during why's the
experience is very different than the
post YC experience building your company
what have you learned since YC hope that
you'd like to share
so I mean everybody has a slightly
different experience after YC for us
obviously closing fundraising was
something that took effort from me and
John that was two months after YC just
we had actually kind of pulled the round
together but doing the documentation and
paperwork took a long time because we
priced the round instead of doing safes
so if you can do saves two safes that's
advice number one beyond that you know
the the hardest thing that I think we've
encountered since YC is keeping up the
momentum YC is just great at giving you
this like excuse for everyone to work
really hard like nobody took vacation
all that stuff so there was a little bit
of like a post YC hangover for the
company because we don't push ourselves
really hard and then we had to like kick
everyone back in the gear right after we
closed fundraising and just start
blazing ahead hmm
so if I were to do it again I would be I
mean it's easy to say this in retrospect
but I would be thinking about that
during YC and right afterwards like
while you as a founder are really
distracted with fundraising maybe the
one thing you should focus on is like
keeping everyone else motivated and
moving even if you're gonna kind of be
busy and out of the loop mm-hmm that's
my experience I guess we're also a
little bit larger than probably the
average YC company is so true we were 16
people in YC mm-hmm yeah I mean there
definitely are some even larger
companies but you guys were on that
larger end I'm one idea on that that I
found really useful for me when running
my company is I guess I guess so I guess
the obvious forcing function you can
give yourself as just PR and media so
you just tell the media you're gonna
launch something in two months and then
you could use that as a way to rally the
team that works but you can't do that
all the time um so the other thing that
we used to do that was quite useful is
we used to set up much like YC did these
demo days where we didn't fight
everyone's friends family and most
importantly significant others to demo
what they've
and people would sign up ahead of time
and say oh you know by you know next
month Samuel day I'm gonna have this and
it turns out when you like towel your
significant other that like you're gonna
have built a thing by a date you really
care because you don't want to look like
a fool and so that provides kind of
synthetic internal forcing function and
you can make it like a fun event invited
people over to the office kind of
humanized the company to all the folks
that don't work there and I found quite
a bit that instilled pressure in the
team that we wouldn't have had otherwise
hmm okay cool
this was great thanks guys Thanks thank
you so much please change the future of
manufacturing in America for the better
we're working on it
you